I just wanted to take a minute to say
that it really is an honor to be here I
for many years starting as I was a
postdoc I think I came as a volunteer
and then I coordinated the volunteers so
I know what you're all doing and then I
was a I'm you know a co-director one
year and so it's really it's such a
wonderful opportunity to come today to
be able to actually share my research
and this may actually be the first time
I see the whole concert or the whole
conference in its entirety because
usually I'm running around like a crazy
person behind the scenes doing lots of
things so I would really first like to
just thank you know Emily emcell for
inviting me stuff Axelrod and Perry
Hoffman it's been such an amazing part
of my career to be a part of this
conference and it really feels like
coming home to just speak to you about
my research so what I am gonna talk
about today is the impact of
interpersonal processes on suicidal
behavior in borderline personality
disorder what I want to do is I always
like to give a road map of what I'm
gonna talk about Emily asked me because
I am the first presenter of the day and
because one of the really wonderful and
unique things about this conference is
the mixture of audience members today we
have a wonderful mix of mental health
professionals nurses social workers
psychologists psychiatrists but we also
have family members who have loved ones
who have been diagnosed with borderline
personality disorder either who for many
years or read more recently and we also
have consumers or individuals who have
also been diagnosed and so what I want
to do first is just take a minute to do
a little bit of an overview so that
we're all on the same page in terms of
what the criteria are the prevalence of
BPD then I'm gonna talk about the
prevalence and defines suicide suicidal
behavior for us so that we're on the
same page and often times I really want
to clarify self-injurious behavior from
suicidal behavior to which most of the
presentations today will focus on
suicidal behavior and then the
connections between suicidal behavior
and BPD and then finally I'll get to
some three studies that I've been in
fortune
to be involved in looking at
interpersonal processes and suicidal
behavior and I always like to kind of
bring it back home at the end with some
treatment implications so the Diagnostic
and Statistical Manual which is our
diagnostic Bible of sorts in the mental
health profession defines BPD as a
pervasive pattern of instability of
interpersonal relationships self-image
and effects and market impulsivity
beginning by early adulthood and present
in a variety of context as indicated by
five or more of the following so on this
slide you see the nine main criteria for
BPD frantic efforts to avoid real or
imagined abandonment a pattern of
unstable and intense interpersonal
relationships identity disturbance
impulsivity recurrent suicidal behavior
gestures or threats or self-mutilating
behavior which is going to be the prime
focus of the conference today affective
instability due to a market reactivity
of mood chronic feelings of emptiness
inappropriate intense anger or
difficulty controlling anger and
transient stress-related paranoid
ideation or severe dissociative symptoms
so you could see a lot of criteria and
you need to have five of the criteria in
order to meet the threshold for the
diagnosis so you can see that it really
is a very heterogeneous diagnosis what
this means is that two individuals could
have a diagnosis of BPD and have a very
different symptom profile and that's
always something I think that's
important to keep in mind in fact a
number that I saw once that Marsha
Linehan had had written about was that
there are actually 256 different
combinations to meet criteria for BPD so
you know we talked about this
overarching disorder but it's really
important to remember that there are
individual differences and how the
symptom patterns play out and how the
two individuals can have the same
diagnosis but yet present very
differently and as treatment providers
that's very important for us to always
keep in mind research of course you know
we like to distill things down from nine
we like to have you know parsimony and
to keep things streamlined
so we find that there are three major
kind of clusters of the symptoms
unstable relationships affective
dysregulation and impulsivity and I'm
gonna be talking about all three of
these major clusters today because they
do all connect to increased suicidal
behavior in BPD so how common is BPD we
can see that it's you know typically one
to two percent of the general population
in clinical studies we find that that
percentage goes up about 10% of
outpatients and 20% of inpatients so
again this is why we're here this is an
important disorder that deserves our
attention that deserves the funding as
Emily and his staff in is Perry and have
commented that this really deserves our
attention and deserves the money in
order to develop treatments so suicide
so just to give us an anchoring
definition for today
suicide is defined as the act or an
instance of taking one's own life
voluntarily and intentionally one thing
as mental health professionals that we
often start many of our clinical
interviews with I know that I do it's
it's one of the first things that I not
one of the first things but in in that
first initial meeting it's essential to
ask about suicidal thoughts or ideation
okay this is you know thinking about or
planning to engage in behaviors to end
one's own life because oftentimes the
suicidal ideation will lead to suicidal
behaviors and so it's one of those
essential components of that initial
interview that we have to ask and
sometimes you know I think as Seth
commented a little bit sometimes we're
hesitant as professionals to ask or we
don't jump in there and unfortunately
you know that does a disservice to our
clients we have to be able to ask the
question it is suicide is one of the top
five causes of death for individuals
between the ages of five and forty four
and completed suicides account for
roughly thirty eight thousand deaths per
year in the United States but the number
of attempts or non completers as they're
called
the literature is actually much higher
and can range from four to 200 times
higher now these statistics that you
have are from 2012 and a couple of weeks
ago I woke to an article in The New York
Times so this slide is not in your
program and I apologize but I thought it
was important for us to to really get
the updated statistics um you know the
headline from the New York Times was you
know us suicide rate surges to a 30-year
high and that was really striking to me
and something that I really felt like we
wanted to highlight so this was a
national center for health statistics
report tracking suicide rate from 1999
to 2014 and we see that right now it's
the highest it's been the suicide rate
in the United States is the highest it's
been since nineteen eighty six thirteen
completed suicides per 100,000 people
and in fact it was the very staggering
number of forty two thousand seven
hundred and seventy-three people died
from suicide in 2014 one of the
statistics that really jumped out to me
that I thought was also particularly
relevant for today was the high jump in
suicide rate for middle-aged women ages
45 to 64 as well as for girls ages 10 to
14 we know that you know while men are
diagnosed with borderline personality
disorder it tends to be more prevalent
in females and to me this rate really
stood out and what was really sobering
to me was the girls ages between 10 and
14 that in fact that suicide rate from
1999 to 2014 had jumped 200% and so that
really sat with me as a human individual
and as a treatment provider that this
really is something that we need to be
aware of and we need to be assessing
earlier and looking for these risk
factors so we know that clinical
populations are at risk for elevated
rates of suicide and this is clinical
populations across the spectrum so major
depressive disorder bipolar disorder
schizophrenia and personality disorders
and that individuals with a prior
history of suicide attempts are more
likely to make a subsequent attempt than
those with no attempt history but I
would caution us to not just look at
individuals with an attempt history
right we have to also be aware that
sometimes individuals will commit
suicide if even if they don't have that
history but it's always good to to keep
in mind the risk associated there and I
just want to remind us that one of the
major criteria for BPD is that recurrent
suicidal behavior gestures are threats
right so we're seeing the repeated Ness
as being something that's really
important for us to keep in mind one of
the other pieces of that criteria is
self-mutilating behavior and we're not
gonna focus or I'm not going to at least
today's focus so much on self-mutilating
our self injurious behavior but I would
just want to make sure that we can see
that we talked a little bit about the
distinction very quickly so
self-mutilating are self injurious
behavior is self-destructive self
directed deliberate destruction or
alteration of bodily tissue with the
absence of suicidal intent okay so
cutting burning and other behaviors both
suicidal behavior and self injurious
behavior are associated with you know
the desire to alleviate suffering to end
distress to end you know negative effect
but what we find is the intention is
different remember that in suicidal
behavior the intent is to end life with
self injurious behavior the intent is
not always to end life though that can
happen often
you know the lethality tends to be lower
for self injurious behavior then with
suicidal behavior but again would just
like to remind us that self injurious
behavior can also lead to suicide at
either accidentally and then frequency
tends to be higher for self injurious
events so in a sample of adult
outpatients we find that the mean
lifetime number of self injurious events
averages around 156 versus mean lifetime
suicide attempts around
- self injurious behavior is a risk
factor for subsequent suicidal behavior
and prior history of self-injury is one
of the strongest predictors of future
suicide attempts so again that's why it
becomes incredibly important to assess
both for suicidal ideation self
injurious behavior because this can then
lead to subsequent suicidal behavior so
specifically with BPD compared to other
clinical groups remember I said that
having clinical groups or at an elevated
risk for engaging in suicidal behavior
and compared to other clinical groups
those individuals with BPD have a higher
number of lifetime suicide attempts they
have an earlier age of first suicide
attempt and the relative risk for
suicide attempts ranges from 3 to 10
times higher so again it's highlights
for us why it's really important for
this conference today to really be
focusing in on assessing and treating
BPD and specifically assessing for
suicidality given this association
between BPD and suicidal behavior it's
really unsurprising that research really
has tried to focus on investigating the
predictors of suicide attempts in this
population and specifically for my talk
today two of the major predictors of
effects problems with effects regulation
and problems with interpersonal
functioning is where I'm gonna spend
most of my time today other talks will
discuss other predictors that are
associated with suicidal behavior and
BPD so two studies that really for me
kind of laid the groundwork of the
research that I'm going to present to
you today was one study by stringer and
colleagues in 2013 that showed that
individuals with high BPD traits who
also reported greater difficulty with
management of anger and aggressive
behaviors were at increased risk for
repeated suicide attempts following-up
yen and colleagues also found that
suicidal adolescents diagnosed with BPD
were rated as having more anger and
hostility than their non BPD counterpart
now what was interesting was that yen
and colleagues also found that problems
with a flex regulation characterized all
of the suicidal subjects in their study
regardless of BPD diagnosis which really
led to to me and my colleagues wondering
whether impairments and ethics
regulation and interpersonal functioning
were risk factors for suicidal behavior
across all clinical groups or was there
something more specific to BPD and also
that there was this research showed this
greater likelihood of suicidal crises
being preceded by an interpersonal
trigger and I started to wonder what
what could these types of interpersonal
triggers be what is it about the
interpersonal world that could then lead
to these suicidal crises so this really
leads us to the first study that I'm
gonna talk about looking at chronicity
of suicidal behavior in individuals with
BPD and specifically impairments in
object relations so what are object
relations you know one of the things
that I always think about with
psychology or psychological theories in
general is that we really like our
jargon we really like to you know object
relations it's really not always what it
sounds like it you know should be and so
I want us to think about I wanted to
just kind of step back and talk about
that because it really is the groundwork
for a lot of what I'm going to talk
about today so object relations is
really simply a template for how we view
ourselves and other people and I want us
to I want to encourage us to think about
when we see the word object we want to
kind of replace it with person or people
okay this can be an actual person it can
be fantasy it can be an image it can be
an internal model of somebody it really
is you know object again that jargony
word of why in the world with
psychoanalytic theorists want to call
people objects we should go back and ask
them all but that's you know that's
where we're at so really want to think
about this template for how we view
ourselves and other people it's really
how do we organize information
that we're taking in all of the time
about ourselves about the people around
us about our significant others about
our friends our family and it is in fact
you know it is based a lot on our
developmental experiences we start to
develop our object relations from very
early on in childhood through our
interactions with our caregivers our
interactions with you know our playmates
our object war our object relational
world our people world starts to get
populated it really is about this cast
of characters that we have in our
everyday lives and the cast of
characters that we have in our minds you
know we have you know representations we
have images of the important people to
us and so it really is kind of how we
think about and how we organize our
interpersonal in our social world and
because of this it includes two major
components which I'll be focusing in a
lot on today which is the cognitive
component which is really how we think
about ourselves and how we think about
other people and our after the affective
component how we feel about ourselves
and how we feel about other people and
so there's a long line of research that
says when we have adaptive object
relations we have relatively stable and
consistent views of ourselves and of
other people which makes it easier for
us to tolerate negative affect and it
makes it easier for us to tolerate
negative interpersonal experiences so an
example of that would be you know I have
a you know relatively stable sense of
myself as a good researcher good
psychologist someone who's fairly
extroverted that could stand up here
today and give a talk to an auditorium
full of people about my research and you
know so this is a fairly consistent self
view and stable image that I have if
today goes really badly and tonight at
dinner Emily says
that talk you know who's a little
confusing no one could really follow you
I'm gonna feel bad right I'm gonna have
I'm gonna have an increase in negative
effect I'm gonna feel maybe embarrassed
I'm gonna feel sad I might be angry I
might be angry at myself I might get a
little angry at Emily for giving me that
feedback tonight at dinner and not just
letting me enjoy it and so I'm gonna you
know so there's gonna be a lot of
negative effect and that's gonna be a
negative interpersonal experience
between Emily and I for tonight
with if with adaptive object relations
if my view of myself and my view of
emily is fairly stable and consistent
i'm gonna bounce back from that maybe by
the time I get back to Brooklyn tonight
maybe tomorrow it'll take me you know
through Sunday but I'm gonna bounce back
in my relationship with Emily will
bounce back okay if I have more impaired
object relations that means that I have
a lot more fluctuations and how I view
myself and how I view other people and
so getting that feedback having that
negative interpersonal interaction
having that increase in negative effects
is actually gonna be much harder for me
to tolerate and it's gonna maybe shift
and shake how I feel about myself and
how I feel about Emily and I may not be
able to recover as quickly from that and
we know that individuals who are
diagnosed with BPD struggle with that
they struggle with the view of
themselves of being fluctuating more
that it makes it harder to tolerate that
negative effect that increased a
negative effect it makes it harder to
tolerate those negative interpersonal
experiences and so I think that's why
it's really important for us to think
about how these object relations
impaired object relations
you know fluctuations and how we view
ourselves and view other people could
lead to suicidal behavior and BPD in
general we know that there is a link
between impairments and object relations
and vulnerability for suicidal behavior
in a long line of empirical studies
to that I'm going to focus on is Tomi
and colleagues in 2000 found the
internal beliefs that other people can't
be trusted was associated with increased
suicidal behavior so again thinking
about that if you feel that the world is
unsafe people can't be trusted
leading to more crises more suicidal
behavior this is not would be a PD
diagnosis in there yet this is just in
general that if you have more
fluctuations and how you view yourself
and others and you have this more more
belief that other people can't be
trusted or the world isn't safe this is
increased to suicidal behavior Kaslow at
all found that patients hospitalized
following a suicide attempt to report it
increased negative views of themselves
and other people lower emotional
investment in their relationship so this
is lower compassion and care in
relationships and lower complexity and
how they describe themselves and other
people so here complexity refers to you
know do you have a kind of nuanced image
are you able to kind of have empathy for
yourself empathy for others perspectives
taking for self and others what we found
when we were doing the literature review
is that we know that there's a link
between BPD and suicidal behavior we
know that there is a link between
impaired object relations and suicidal
behavior and we know that there's a link
between impaired object relations and
BPD but no study had actually put them
all together and so that's really for
this first study what we wanted to do we
wanted to look at the impact of
object-relational impairment on suicidal
patients that were diagnosed with BPD
and we hypothesized that the quality of
object relations either adaptive or
impaired would in fact interact with BPD
diagnosis to predict chronicity of
suicidal behavior and specifically that
chronicity of suicidal behavior would be
highest in subjects with greater
impairments in object relations who were
also diagnosed with BPD so I was very
fortunate to have colleagues who were
working at the Austin Riggs Center which
is in northern
Massachusetts and we had 131 subjects
this was data taken from the states of
mind preceding a near lethal suicide
attempt with the principal investigator
with dr. Jane Tillman at Austin Riggs
all of our participants resided in at
Austin Riggs which is an intensive
residential treatment facility and the
average length of stay for our
participants from admission to study
participation so this you know they they
may have continued to stay at Austin
Riggs beyond but was twenty two weeks
from admission to study participation we
did exclude anyone who had a suicide
attempt while they were admitted to
Austin Riggs and anyone who had a size
of psychosis or schizophrenia you can
see mostly female sample mean age around
thirty three primarily Caucasian some
college education and we did have 54% of
the sample with prior suicide attempts
so 71 of the participants had prior
suicide attempt and the number of prior
suicide attempts ranged from one attempt
to 12 attempts just a little bit of
diagnostic information I'm not gonna go
too much into this other than to say
that there were 29 patients diagnosed
with BPD and that suicide attempters
were more likely to be diagnosed with
BPD in this sample than any other
diagnosis so how do we assess object
relations it's not that easy it turns
out it's not as you know it's not as
simple as being able to give a
self-report measure god I love it when
we can do that it makes it so much
easier this is a little bit more of a
labor of love to assess object relations
we we do what's called the social
cognition an object relation scale it's
a rating scale that gets applied to
stories and in this case stories that
participants tell and in this case we
used the thematic apperception test or
the t-80 test which is a series of cards
and on the cards used
you know some sort of scene that often
is one person or more than one and want
more than one person and the idea here
is we ask the participant or a client or
consumer to tell us a story about this
scene that's being depicted on the card
the idea here is we asked we prompt for
thoughts for wishes and for the feelings
of the characters this lets us really
get at the kind of unconscious or out of
awareness ideas that we have about
ourselves and about other people and so
you can see on them you can see one of
the example t-80 cards that we used in
the study and so what you do is you
would ask the participant to tell a
story about the card so you know my
story it might be that here's a woman
she's on the floor she maybe has
received some you know upset or
distraught news about a loved one so
you're already seeing my object
relations right a young woman distraught
news and so you know and that she's you
know very worried about what's gonna
happen okay so that would be my kind of
object-relational story here to the t-80
card and it's out of you know and what
happens is with these stories we have a
team of Raiders or coders who then go
through and assess for object relations
using different scales and so remember I
said before that we have both the
affective and the cognitive components
that we're looking at okay the affective
scales include things how do we manage
aggression right so in my story that I
told you there was no aggression so
either I'm really good at managing
aggression or perhaps I'm denying
aggression right because there was an
absence of any kind of aggression of my
story effective quality right I had sad
I had upset I had distraught emotional
investment in values this is kind of
compassion and appreciation for
interpersonal values and relationships
self-esteem stability of self-concept
caring commitment and engagement those
are the effective themes that we're
looking for and so someone could take my
story and rate it for my effective
object-relational quality on the flip
side we can also look at how do I think
about myself how do I think about other
people and look at the cognitive scales
so these are things like how do I
understand social causality can I
understand what's the causal links
between motivations feelings and
behaviors remember for my story I said
that she had received some bad news
and was feeling upset so that would be
the causal link there was some kind of
cognitive I would process or complexity
to the story and then complex
representations of people perspectives
taking empathy understanding and
understanding the motivations of self
and other people and so we take these
stories that participants tell us to the
t-80 cards and we come up with ratings
on affective and cognitive object
relations and we hypothesized that
impairments are lower scores on both
facets both the affective quality and
the cognitive quality of object
relations would lead to greater suicidal
behavior in individuals with BPD and we
didn't find that for the first facet so
we first looked at the affective link
and so the there was no significant
relationship so the quality of the
effective interpersonal object relations
did not interact with BPD diagnosis to
predict lifetime suicide attempts but
what was interesting is that it was the
cognitive facet so how we think about
ourselves and how we think about other
people the social causality the ability
to kind of link up kind of cause and
effect the ability to have
perspective-taking and empathy
interacted with BPD diagnosis to predict
lifetime suicide attempts and so let's
just look here so we can see that the
effect of BPD diagnosis on suicide
attempts is most pronounced
right so this is lifetime suicide
attempts going here and the object
relations the content of how we think
about ourselves and other people down
here so you can see that BPD diagnosis
was more pronounced at low or more
impaired levels of the cognitive facet
of object relations so in other words
participants who were diagnosed with BPD
in this study as compared to those
without BPD which is this line we're
more likely to have a greater number of
past suicide attempts if they had
impairments in the cognitive aspects if
they had more impairments in social
causality finding that cause and effect
finding that link and also if they had
more impairments in terms of prospective
taking in their relationships and how
they think about themselves and empathy
for themselves and other people and so
really what this started to suggest is
that difficulties with perspective
taking and understanding motivations
feelings and behaviors is in fact
important in this population and gives
us a point of trying to intervene and
trying to think through how can we
assess for and how can we possibly
prevent subsequent suicidal behavior
what we also saw was the impaired object
relations was not just a general risk
factor for suicidal behavior so this
line down here is relatively flat it
really was having the BPD diagnosis
interacting with the impaired object
relations on the cognitive aspect it
wasn't just a general risk factor in
this sample it was something specific to
individuals diagnosed with BPD on the
flip side one of the things I always
like to think about is what are we
striving for right what are we thinking
about as mental health professionals
where do we want to move our consumers
and our clients to and thinking about
how adaptive object relations could
really serve as a protective mechanism
in this study and so we had you know we
were looking at the PD diagnosis and as
I said before impulsivity is an
important part of the symptom profile of
BPD and so we were wondering that if we
didn't just look at
we didn't just look at the BPD diagnosis
but rather took a facet of the VPD
diagnosis that we know is very much
linked with suicidal behavior
impulsivity if we would see the same
relationship and so impulsivity you know
is defined as the tendency to act on a
whim with little or no reflection of
consequences or consideration of
consequences
we know that impulsivity is an important
risk factor for suicidal behavior and
specifically what's called negative
urgency or impulsive behavior in the
context of negative effect right so high
negative effect we see more impulsivity
which then can lead to more suicidal
crises and we started to wonder would
the capacity to manage impulsivity would
that be related to how we view ourselves
and other people could object relations
impact that capacity to manage impulsive
urges if I have a stable sense of myself
and a stable sense of other people would
that buffer me from having more suicidal
crises or more suicidal behavior so
again we wanted to look at that question
and we hypothesized that object will
again impaired object-relational
functioning would be associated with
heightened risk for chronic suicidal
behavior in highly impulsive individuals
but not for individuals that were low in
impulsivity and so we had the same
participants that we used in study 1 so
again we use the same Austin Riggs
sample but instead of looking at the BPD
diagnosis we were able to look at
impulsivity as a continuous measure so
again we use those t-80 cards and the
stories that were told in the codes to
the affective and the cognitive object
relations and this time we used the
Barrett impulsiveness scale which had
three sub sub scales that we also looked
at so attentional impulsiveness which is
the capacity to maintain concentration
and sustained focus which if you have
the attentional impulsiveness you don't
have the capacity to maintain
concentration and sustained focus motor
impulsive Nisour the tendency to engage
in impulsive decision-making or
unplanned
action an on planning impulsive Ness
which is the inability to plan and
prepare for future events and the
inability to consider cause and
consequence so one of the first things
we wanted to do was to just see were
there any differences between
individuals in our study who had a
previous suicide attempt and those that
had no history of suicide attempts in
terms of impulsivity and there were no
significant differences in impulsivity
between suicide attempters and
non-attempters
which we were actually surprised about
this was an unexpected finding for us
typically research shows that there is a
link between impulsivity and suicidal
behavior and suicide attempts so
something maybe about our sample at
Austin Riggs this didn't the same
connection didn't hold their impulsivity
on its own did not distinguish between
those who made a suicide attempt and
those who did not but we do see
something important happen again when we
add in the object relations when we add
in how we view ourselves and other
people and so specifically what we found
was an interaction between the non
planning impulsiveness with impairment
in managing managing aggressive impulses
was predictive of lifetime suicide
attempts so remember that non planning
impulsivity is not being able to plan
for the future not considering cause and
effect and how cause and effect you know
go together and that that interacts with
a poor ability to manage aggressive
aggression and aggressive impulses to
predict lifetime suicide attempts and so
we can see the relationship here so the
light green our participants I guess
it's not light green here look but light
green red green here
Hainan planning impulsivity were more
likely to have higher numbers of past
suicide attempts if they also
demonstrated really significant
impairments in managing aggressive
impulses - four standard deviations
below the mean was
low in terms of being able to manage
aggressive impulses this means that
those stories that they were telling to
the t-80 cards were incredibly
aggressive and had a lot of aggressive
affect and difficulty kind of managing
it was really kind of coming out across
all of the stories that they were
telling to all of the different cards
and so you know just to kind of put it
all together for this particular study
no global differences in impulsivity
levels between suicide attempters and
non-attempters which we didn't expect
and I think is an interesting area and
potentially due to our restricted sample
at Austin ranks but here we saw that
individuals high in impulsivity how they
feel about themselves and how they feel
about other people this difficulty with
managing those aggressive impulses
managing difficulties managing hostility
really leading to more increase in
suicidal behavior and so there was this
interaction between on planning and
pulse if attea the difficulties with
planning for the future difficulties
anticipating cause and effect leading to
a greater number of lifetime suicide
attempts I think one of the really
strengths of this particular study and
why I wanted to highlight it is we often
you know we know that there was a link
right between difficulties with
hostility and anger leading to more
suicidal behavior but those studies were
really done with those self-report
measures kind of kind of checklists and
and you know circle yes or no or I'm on
a scale of 1 to 5 how angry do I feel
right now and what I really like about
this is again we're getting at that
non-conscious that out of our awareness
feelings of anger and aggression that
again really points to the fact that
it's incredibly important for us to to
do so really quickly since apparently
I'm running out of time I want to just
really briefly go into a study that I'm
really excited about because my work
is primarily focused on understanding
interpersonal functioning across
different diagnostic groups and so one
of the things that I was really the two
studies within object relations really
led me to think what specifically are
the interpersonal difficulties that are
you know that challenge our individuals
our patients that are diagnosed with BPD
and lead to more suicidal crises what
are the interpersonal risk factors is
there a particular interpersonal profile
that we esteem it provider x' could
really think about and think about how
we could you know use treatment
interventions to target these
interpersonal processes and so i'm
actually gonna just skip quickly since i
only have 15 minutes and talk a little
bit about the two theories of suicidal
behaviour to psychological theories of
suicidal behaviors that have shaped my
kind of interest in this question so the
escape theory by Baumeister which
describes kind of the failure to attain
a standard or a goal as leading to kind
of suicidal behavior suicidal crises or
an unbearable negative self-awareness
and that this theory really focuses a
lot on achievement and confidence and
that difficulties in attaining kind of
achievement in confidence really leading
then to suicidal behavior on the flip
side Seth mentioned earlier Thomas
joiner the interpersonal psychological
theory of suicide and the idea of kind
of thwarted belongingness or an unmet
need to belong and perceived
burdensomeness or an unmet need for
social confidence kind of leading to and
so there's this intense desire to
connect and to belong and to be engaged
in interpersonal relationships but
feeling as though it's difficult to
connect or can't connect and that that
leads with a quired capability or an
accumulation of adverse in painful
experiences leads to an increase in
suicidal behavior and I think that
that's a really important thing for us
to kind of to keep in mind
unmet need this thwarted belongingness
and perceived burdensomeness and so the
escape theory and the interpersonal
psychological theory describe kind of
two sets of needs and I wanted to look
at is there's what are the specific
interpersonal problems that could you
know is it about more about this escape
theory more about agency more about
control in relationships or is it really
more about this wanting to connect
wanting to belong wanting to engage in
relationships that really is what
happens and so this led me to do an
interpersonal assessment and so what is
an interpersonal assessment it's looking
at the specific types of interpersonal
problems so what are the things that I
have a difficult time doing in my
relationships what are the specific
types of interpersonal sensitivities so
what frustrates me what bothers me what
irritates me in my relationships with
other people and then what are the
specific types of interpersonal values
what do I want in my relationships right
and so for Kermit here right he likes to
he values his friendships he wants to be
connected he maybe he's sensitive to
some of the controlling behaviors by
some of his friends and maybe he has
problems telling some of his Muppet
friends what his you know his needs are
in their in relationships and so that
really started to think could we come up
with an interpersonal profile that would
characterize individuals who are high on
BPD and high on suicidality and could we
link this interpersonal profile back to
psychological theories of suicide that
either the unmet need for belonging
mnestheus cape or the achievement more
more achievement related difficulties so
just really quickly we did this in a non
clinical sample this time so it was a
hundred and twenty under 129
undergraduate students from an urban
multicultural University I won't go
through all the demographics in the
interest of time but 39
six of our percent of our sample had
reported that they had thought about or
attempted to kill themselves in their
lifetime and that 4.3 percent reported
that they had attempted suicide or
intentionally self harms in the past
year which was very sobering for me I'm
also in addition to being a researcher
and a clinician I'm a professor and
these are my students and I teach
introduction to psychology and many of
these students were my students when
they participated in the study and so
that really kind of was very sobering to
me as the professor so we had 37
participants who were high on VPD
features using the personality
assessment inventory and high on
suicidal behavior so what that meant was
these were participants who were one
standard deviation above the mean on BPD
criteria and who also endorsed that item
that they thought about or attempted to
kill themselves in the past year and so
you know again it's a very small sample
it's a non clinical sample but I think
some interesting things kind of do
emerge and so what we found as a profile
for these high BPD and high suicidality
participants was that they had
interpersonal problems related to being
overly warm overly nurturance in their
relationships and so what this meant was
items here are I put others others needs
above mine too much I try to please
other people too much I'm affected by
another person's misery too much so
these are the problems that they're
having in their relationships they're
irritated or frustrated or bothered by
cold remote withdrawn behavior and other
people so this is something so important
for us as family members as friends as
treatment providers to keep in mind okay
and that what they value what they want
in their relationship is they value
being able to express themselves openly
they value being heard in their
relationships with others
and so to me what this said this profile
again it's a very preliminary 37
participants non clinical sample but
what this really said to me was this
really looks a lot like that thwarted
belongingness that perceived
burdensomeness that we were seeing in
joiners theory the psychological
interpersonal theory and that this
really kind of gives us an interpersonal
profile that we can work with in
treatment as treatment providers that
these are the individuals who are high
on BPD features and high on suicidal
behavior they want to feel as they can
be open in their relationships that they
can relate to other people they wish for
this in their relationships they get
bothered by remoteness or pulling back
behaviors by other people and that to
compensate they may end up engaging and
very overly warm overly nurturing
putting other people first too much
which could then be very problematic for
them in their relationships and so again
that kind of sorted belongingness and
perceived burdensomeness again very
small non clinical sample but we are
starting to collect this data at the
austin reg center starting this AAG at
this summer so we can kind of extend it
then into the clinical population so I
think you know in terms of concluding
remarks I really want to jump more ahead
and jump to the treatment implications
because I think this is really where I
want us to be thinking about how can we
take this information from these studies
and really think about treatment so
targeting views of how we view ourselves
and how we view other how we view other
people is incredibly important we saw
that how we think about and how we feel
about ourselves and other people
mattered in terms of predicting
increased numbers of suicide attempts
and the adaptive object relations
relatively stable consistent sense of
self and others was a protective
mechanism in both study one in studies
here that there was less suicidal
behavior
improving perspective taking improving
an understanding social causality could
really help individuals who are
struggling with BPD and who are also
struggling with suicidal behavior so
this leads me to think about
mentalization based interventions all of
you know Peter Funaki and Anthony
bateman's work you know the
interpersonal profile also kind of
reminded me of being able to target
through interpersonal effectiveness in
DBT right an increasing self-respect
increasing objective effectiveness
what's important in terms of maintaining
relationships that would really help us
to target that inter personal profile
and address for today honest and
perceived burdensomeness and then
finally also reducing impulsivity and
difficulties with managing aggression
and anger and again I was I was brought
back to DBT there as well with
mindfulness you know emotion regulation
and distress tolerance and so I would
like to just acknowledge my
collaborators as well as my research
assistants I can't do anything without
my research assistants so I just wanted
to acknowledge them thank you
[Applause]
thank you very much Nicole so we if you
have questions you can are we good
we had a question about the study
looking at impulsivity and aggression
were you able to distinguish between
aggression toward the self like self
loathing versus aggression towards
others and if so was aggression towards
self more likely to predict number of
lifetime suicide unfortunately we
couldn't I think it's a great question
what happens when we take those t-80
cards is that aggression is just a
global score and so we're not able in
that moment to tease apart what's the
self like self-directed aggression
versus other directed aggression I think
that would be a really wonderful thing
if we could go back into the data and do
that it's just when we collapse the when
we collapse that it really kind of is
just managing aggression in general
rather than specific to self er to other
unfortunately there we go one other
question about
the Austin rig sample that you had do
you think there's any implication
towards the given that the Austin rig
sample was probably very different and
yes than some of your other yeah samples
and do you think that explains any
differences I do I you know I think it's
something that you know when we were
thinking about the data and when we were
writing up the papers in particular that
we really wanted to make sure that we
addressed that as a as a limitation this
is not your usual sample of impatience
or outpatients even and so I think some
of the the odd findings of impulsivity
not predicting that impulsivity didn't
distinguish between suicide attempters
and non-attempters I mean where I went
immediately was this is the Austin Rae
example they just may be less impulsive
in general because have more resources
there's less less going on so I
absolutely think so I would love to get
a broader clinical population that gets
out of that limitation of SES well thank
you very much dr. King we appreciate
that so let's give a round of applause
for dr.
[Applause]
[Music]